did you see that rogan is talking about
suing cnn for saying that he was using
uh what was it horse dewormer ivamekton
okay but okay but listen he went like
this he he literally went like this
should i [ __ ] should i [ __ ] sue
cnn ended
like kind of like that
very in passing that just goes to show
how powerful that dude's voice is
he opened the show talking about the
dewormer thing and he goes [ __ ] should i
sue uh cnn
and like
i don't know i don't know how serious
that was i don't think it's really
serious at all no
but but um
basically
it's really funny
because i did see you know philip
defranco you know philip defranco
he's a you know big youtuber kind of
like a news guy
and he's just like i'm so sick of he he
goes crazy
he goes crazy on joe rogan
and what's funny is what does he say if
i mean he went he went nuts he was like
i'm so sick and tired of the same [ __ ]
uh you know like
uh you know joe rogan not pushing the
vaccine and and giving misinformation
and all of this stuff
and it sounded weird because it's like
did you even watch
the full video that rogan had made
again it was so non-politically
charged it was so nice it was so hopeful
he had a smile on his face he was in his
back [ __ ] yard he was he was like
look we did everything we could we we
sent everything through the kitchen sink
at it we threw the kitchen sink at it i
you know i had ivermectin as well i had
this this and this i rested up i stayed
and i feel great and i'm just really
happy to be here and i'm all this [ __ ]
and everyone took that and phil defranco
himself took that and was like look at
this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] i i'm sorry
if you were to take someone who had just
never interacted with the world just an
alien and brought them down here and
they watched someone say what they what
they had said they would have been like
oh that's completely inconsequential and
i just don't give a [ __ ] because it was
just so mild
and then they walk away is it not the
same people that are saying joe rogan
shouldn't have put this weird stuff in
his body because it's a bad virtue
signal to everyone else that are also
saying my body my choice with regards to
the texas abortion law
so
wait say that one more time
people are complaining about the fact
that rogan's used experimental drugs on
himself right he is in a position of
influence and other people may decide to
do the same thing that also say
abortion shouldn't be restricted down to
six weeks my body my choice well see
rogan's body rogan's choice that doesn't
work
ah
interesting you've thought about that
one huh joel did that just come to just
just came to your mind yep
oh man you're good at this you're a pro
so
yeah i mean that's the al always the
cool the funniest thing is if you're if
you're saying listen i don't want to
wear a mask i don't want to take a
vaccine if i don't have to you better be
saying
you know you can get an abortion if you
want
um because it's your body your choice
it's my body my choice vaccine or not
whatever
and uh that is a very very interesting
point
you know the thing that's interesting i
think about rogan's situation is how the
press responded to it so it's the fact
that every
opportunity for something to become
politicized
someone tries to take them for part of
his team so because roger hasn't had the
vaccine the right decided to take this
as this is an opportunity for one of our
own to push back against this
totalitarian state that's trying to
force vaccines into our arms and so on
and so forth every topic
is an opportunity to score points
and and that sucks i'm sorry that sucks
i i i can't
when i was younger i don't think that it
was like this
isn't it i would like to think isn't it
telling i would like to remember whether
it was or not
why beca probably because i've been so
like
immersed
in what we do now that i can't even
can't remember a world in which
it wasn't like this
it's so wild bro i saw a tweet from the
fda
talking about ivamekton
that said you are not a horse
you are not a cow
seriously y'all stop it
that's
those are the people
in charge of your country's okay food
and drug administration okay here we go
so listen the fda
uh
from what i've seen is is an absolute
joke and can be bought and sold
now that doesn't that doesn't
delegitimize the fact that you know one
should or shouldn't get vaccinated
that's not what i'm saying
a lot of their suggestions
on sugar intake artificial
you know sweeteners intake like it's
just off and you can tell it's
they've been basically bought and sold
rather than being outright and and
forthright and telling people how they
should
you know eat and live better lives
through the food that they eat
they
you know allow these um christmas donuts
to give yes free donuts away to people
that got vaccinated
yes and
this is one of those things and you'll
see it on tick tocks okay i'm glad both
of these things are are kind of coming
full circle
there's like friend zone tick tock okay
and one of them is like
dancing with my best friend and it's
like you know it's a girl and a guy and
they're like they're about to kiss and
they fake kiss and then they start
dancing or whatever and all of the
comments are talking about how great of
a guy that guy is
it's like kind of the inside joke it's
like um like
let's say the guy's name is chris okay
the comments will be like you know my
grandma was dying she was dying she was
on the street dying and chris came out
and and gave her open-heart surgery on
the street thank god for chris or else
my grandma would be dead what does this
have to do with the fda okay so
mlb major league baseball comments
chris invented baseball
like
major league baseball yeah okay you so
now you see
and by the way that's a massive
corporation
massive
so much money and they're commenting on
a viral tick tock about a kid getting
friend-zoned
they're trying to
it is now the usurping of
being an actual advertisement making an
actual psa that is where we're at right
now the fda will make a snarky comment
on twitter to sound cool saying y'all
y'all are not cows y'all are not horses
okay
that's where we're at so you're saying
that even the fda will sell their soul
for clout
yeah of course i i wouldn't be surprised
if the fda hops on tick tock and starts
making smarmy snarky comments thank you
very much for tuning in if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe makes me very happy indeed
peace